what is up everybody welcome to another
Raspberry Pi tutorial so now that we
have our Raspberry Pi it's all set up
for the purposes of this tutorial and
probably the next few tutorials I'm
going to be using a raspbian operating
system for everything that we're going
to do if you don't have raspy and you
don't know how to set up your Raspberry
Pi check out some of the previous videos
so with that what we're going to be
doing in this video is overclocking our
PI so to do that you just have to change
a few settings it's very simple and
there's actually kind of two ways to do
it if you have a new Raspberry Pi or
you've got noobs installed there's
actually a setting that you can use it
in the config utility to do it but
that's no fun because that you're not
actually learning anything about your
Raspberry Pi you're just choosing an
option and a premade GUI so actually
let's learn how to change our CPU clock
settings ourselves and but I will show
you guys at the end of the video how to
do it via the config utility as well as
far as warranty is concerned when you
overclock your PI I want to say if you
do it via the config utility you're
still covered under warranty so if you
have a newer PI it depends on what
generation PI you have but don't quote
me on that and you might want to look up
yourself if you're worried about your
warranty but honestly I mean this was
like 35 bucks so I'm not too worried
about it so anyway let's go ahead and
pop in first thing we want to do is open
up your terminal and if you're a little
uncomfortable with the terminal don't
worry probably either the next tutorial
or at least very very soon we'll be
talking about the commands for your
terminal this is good to go ahead and
get comfortable with working inside your
terminals it's very powerful and
eventually you probably are better off
operating your Raspberry Pi what's
called quote unquote headless and just
connecting the like SSH or something
like that and if you do that it will
look
or at least the commands would be very
similar so the first thing that we want
to do is let's go ahead and figure out
what our settings currently are so to do
that you'll type in cat and then we're
gonna go into proc and CPU info and when
we hit that we'll see what our settings
are as you can see it's normally clocked
at I want to see 700 megahertz so that's
what we're sitting at right now now the
goal is to overclock it you might want
to choose 800 just for a nice subtle
overclock or you can go even further and
there's actually two things that we can
overclock here we can overclock the
processor and you can also overclock Ram
and then there's also another
interesting little thing that you can do
which is why probably we'll be talking
about the terminal commands and probably
like a couple of like two videos because
the next thing we will be doing is
meshing the two so they can share their
power
definitely something awesome so now that
we've seen this next thing we want to do
is let's go ahead there's another
command you can do and it is VCG hold on
move my mouse VCG ian CMD get underscore
config and then what what we want to get
from that is the arm underscore
frequency now in my case it's going to
tell me a zero probably in your case
depending on what generation or version
of Pi you have you might get something
else but what it's doing is its
accessing your config file and looking
for the arm underscore frequency
variable and right now I believe it's
telling us your because it's not finding
the variable so it's just kind of like a
null it doesn't exist so anyway so now
what we want to do is go in there into
our config file and config exactly what
we want
so how do we get into our config file so
actually getting into your config file
is pretty simple and again if you're if
you're not familiar with the commands
have a no affair we'll be talking about
them in the next video or at least maybe
a couple videos away
I just first wanted to give you guys a
taste for maybe why you might want to
learn these commands so anyway you want
to do sudo I'm asking sudo nano and now
where do we want to go we want to go
into the boot folder and then within
there there I'm sorry directory and in
there we want to do config that text
that's what we want to put up on the
screen so we need to enter its gonna
open up that file and here it is in this
file even though there's really no
functions in it or anything like that
it's all it's Python really like you can
see these are its Python on there it's
Python comments and so on so the first
thing that we want to do is up here you
could read some of these like if you're
having any of these problems like if
you're not getting any HDMI and you've
got it plugged in you could uncomment
this and usually 0 for false 1 for true
so if you want to turn on HDMI safe mode
you could uncomment this anyway so you
could read those if you want but what
we're interested in is down here at the
bottom now again depending on what
version you have you might have this
here or you might not you might need to
hand type this entire thing out
otherwise if you've got a current
version you could let's see shoot I've
always stopped it hold on me pop back
into it
don't hit control Z anyway coming back
down ok so what we want to do is we want
to edit this frequency but if like I
said if you've already got two here you
just need to uncomment it so once you've
got uncommented it next thing you want
to do is exit and when you exit on exit
it's going to ask you if you want to say
which of course we do
so you'll hit control X for exit save
the modified version Y for yes and then
it's going to ask you what file name you
want to write it to by default it's
going to be the original file name so
we're just gonna hit enter
so we've resaved it basically now in
some instances you'll be able to just
shut down like a restart and that will
do everything you need if you've got
kind of like a newer PI it should work
perfectly fine for us but if it doesn't
there are a couple
options that you can do so just for the
sake of doing it we're gonna run through
those options and so the first thing you
want to do if you want to do sudo sync
the next thing you want to do a sudo SH
- yeah
c1 echo 3 greater than and 6vm we want
to drop caches so we do that and the
next thing we want to do is we're gonna
kind of re spit this file out basically
so we're gonna go through a little bit
of a copy and paste process here so sudo
CP for copy config actually what we need
to do is slash I think it's in Boop
slash config dot txt and then where do
we want to copy it - same thing you want
to copy it to the boot and fig dot txt
and then we want to save that then we
want to do the same thing with one
finally we want to sudo sink sink exit
and then finally one last exit so what
that's gonna do is just gonna cut you
out of your terminal basically so now
what we want to do is shut down the PI
and as always the best way to shut down
the PI it's gonna be actually through
the terminal so let's open it back up
again and we'll just just for good
measure we'll sing run another sync and
then now we'll just do sudo shutdown and
now so what this is going to do now is
we'll shut down our PI and whenever it's
done fully shutting down lights are
stopped blinking yadda yadda what you'll
need to do is unplug the power to your
PI and replug back in your power will
wait for my PI to begin again